Texans asked to conserve energy to
protect the power grid for the second
time in a week Texans have been asked to
turn up the thermostats and avoid using
large appliances from 2 to 9 pm
Wednesday the power grid operator said
it does not expect rolling blackouts and
I think the temperature Tyler if you
want to go up so I can read the rest is
78 there you go 78 degrees for the
second time this week the state's power
grid operators asking Texans to turn up
their thermostats to 78 degrees and to
avoid using large appliances as it
expected record high demand for power
grid ongoing
scorching temperatures it is asking for
conservation 2 to 9 pm interesting so
what do you think when you hear
something like this or you read
something like something like this I
think in the southern states the
temperatures kept too low in most
buildings I think it's 78 is fine I set
my 78. I set mine at 80. I and I come
from Canada but I set my room at 80 here
because when I go outside it's 90 right
and if I come on I feel fine people are
going to hear these numbers what are you
talking about you can sleep at 80. yeah
I can sleep at 80. I just take the
covers on like can you sleep at 80. how
though I'm a 72 Guy it says on my
thermostat not the number right 72 when
you said what 80. I I said it it said
I'm in Miami buddy 80 are you kidding me
I want to feel cool when I sleep are you
are you telling me that people in Texas
should disregard what they're saying and
just keep their thermostat at 80. no no
they should put it at 78 like they say
78 yeah nobody's doing that man no I
know they're not but nobody when you're
from the north right you you set your
thermostat probably at 75. people most
people would set it at 75 or even or
even lower it's true but that's because
it's way colder outside eight months out
of the year you don't even use the AC no
use the heater well I don't we only have
AC in our bedrooms we don't have the
rest of the house okay our condition
just open the windows what about our
friends in Texas and yeah what is it
ercot ercot is that no that's the whole
like the real stupid thing about this is
they're running out of power in Texas
one of the richest places in the world
and the reason they're having this
problem is because of the huge amount of
wind power they put in because it just
isn't there sometimes
a lot of the time it just isn't there
and and this is where people are going
Texas Australia New York Ontario in
Canada
Germany all these countries are going to
come up against this wall
because they just keep building more
wind and solar the plans to build
offshore Upstate New York and off Long
Island there there's plans to build like
vast wind farms offshore now they're
worried about the right whales being
because white whales get have their
birthing up north of there and then come
South and they're going to have to be
navigating through this massive bunch of
wind turbines to get out of there I
maybe it's a made-up thing I mean I
think right whales can probably get past
wind farms but let me ask you a quick
question the thing is the wind farms in
the first place
Maybe I'm Wrong maybe I'm
misinterpreting this but you know in in
economics there's a term laissez-faire
uh economics right where don't do
anything just let free market capitalism
take its place no government
interference whatsoever just it is what
it is led to be what it be is that
essentially the argument that you're
making for climate change or the
environment is just do nothing let let
it be what it be am I misinterpreting
that I spent a great part of my life
stopping toxics from going into the air
and water uh there has to be rules okay
but but when the EPA made the ruling
that CO2 was air pollution instead of
recognizing that it was the main food of
all life on Earth
that was a big mistake and they did it
without
Congress giving them the authority to do
that and that's been ruled against by
the Supreme Court now which is a really
good decision like what that did was it
gave the EPA the power to determine the
entire energy infrastructure and what
technology could and could not be used
nothing to do with clean air the the air
that we we can burn coal clean now it's
being done even in China they're putting
good pollution control on their coal
plants but when you make CO2 a pollutant
the food of life
that's absolutely absolutely nuts CO2 is
not a pollutant what else is on your
checklist like if you're saying all
right no don't do laissez-faire for the
environment like there's some things you
should do is there a certain like 3.5
Point checklist do this do this do this
like you talked about oh well don't CO2
what else it's the don't Do's that
matter don't murder people don't abuse
people you know don't but that's don't
we've known about that since the Ten
Commandments I'm talking about
government interference today which
should be done
well there's no clear answer to that
question it's
it's what shouldn't be done to a large
extent what shouldn't be done is calling
carbon dioxide carbon any just remember
this anybody who calls CO2 carbon don't
listen to a word they say because CO2 is
not carbon it is carbon dioxide we don't
call water hydrogen water is hydrogen
dioxide right I learned that from The
Waterboy shout out to Adam Sandler so
you don't call it hydrogen just because
it's the first letter in the for in the
formula so these people are calling it
carbon because they want you to think of
soot right well why don't they want you
to think of diamonds because that's pure
carbon too and so is graphite what our
pencils have in them carbon is a miracle
element
and CO2 is a miracle molecule
because all the carbon in all life comes
from CO2 in the air and the ocean that's
where it comes from and fossil fuels are
made with carbon that came from life so
all of fossil fuels were made with solar
energy
have you heard that before
no well how else did the oil and gas or
from marine animals and the coal is from
forests on the land
that they were made with solar energy
That's the basis of all life turning
carbon dioxide and water into sugar and
then the sugar is the energy for all of
life from there on up to us
all life
and if we threaten our own food system
with these stupid rules about not using
nitrogen or carbon dioxide maybe they're
going to ban carbon dioxide in
greenhouses the next thing you know
people are working in there in CO2
levels two and three times what it is in
the atmosphere and actually right in
this room now CO2 will be at least
double what it is out in the air
because of our breathing we breathe out
two pounds of CO2 every day and the you
know the atmosphere is now 420 parts per
million CO2 when we exhale it's 40 000
parts per million CO2 because we're
taking in oxygen and breathing out CO2
the plants take in CO2 and breathe out
oxygen so it's a perfect cycle
and that's how that's nature in a
nutshell so if you like this clip and
you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]